welcome to this video playing Grand
Master bhumika here John GM and he's
completely dumbfounded by c6 know he
probably just grabbed a drink or
something ok we cut them I could do
something that's Mary maybe this line
haven't played that too often I don't
really know what that that well or at
all I know that h6 is answered by 96 I
actually overlook this once and I'm in a
blitz game ok this is not a very common
come on line but may be interesting or
playable let's aim hmm but what happens
if i go Bishop g4 this night f7 Cromley
ok age what what if i go h6 now is there
some i can still take on f7 okay okay
can he 95 maybe may try that it's a it's
interesting neide f7 king of 795 king g
8 i'm not sure that this is winning and
if he needs if he must retreat time then
the whole setup wasn't too bad probably
kind of funny yeah him he tried a check
of course my light square has a terribly
weak but I didn't see a direct win so
still interesting you should see for
it's not on yeah this is also not the
thread queen bee three I am actually
have my doubts that this is that this is
really a valid valid line it's only
encamped uncomfortable to play on course
sorry yeah still be should be six why
not we should be 62 f 7 also guarding
guarding a g6
I probably wants to Castle long maybe I
can can play against that with 25 yeah
see 4 i'm going to take going to take
deform i take g two you will cancel no I
guess well yeah why not so you couldn't
cancel long
yeah that it's not easy to play him if
he goes f4 I mean the position is really
not not coordinated by any means and
this I just overlooked how idiotic is
that ah come on very simple let's move I
just I was only thinking about taking at
Bishop c4 warden but Bishop c4 Noah yeah
this just blundered away this game not
even possible to continue here maybe
with this to have two pieces at least
for the Queen but I'm not sure I mean
before that it wasn't a total we know
anything I think like objectively
speaking was certainly better but very
difficult to play in a blitz game so it
wasn't it wasn't it wasn't winning or
anything you know and then this time
this time control okay I still continue
but maybe I get some some places for the
pieces and can can fight but very
unlikely Brooke is coming here
you gave aid some hope on f2 yeah not
not really but i can trade routes this
is a very helpful for white with using
my already very slight potential for any
for any tricks can also double on the
seventh probably rook c7 rheumatism
a very very greedy continuation probably
had probably still good for what I have
I have needs like 93 but they don't
threaten much I can go be should be ATM
but I'm not sure that it helps maybe
still
why is YC moving it's there's there's
trick now that i'm not seeing I don't
see any trick
hmm
yeah it's probably just just a complete
win but
I can get it to g6 it's a check that's
pretty hopeless but
yeah h4 would be quite quite convincing
yeah my time morning must do that
actually
way to continue I am the idiot of the
week prize goes to me goes to me yeah 97
oh what a holla yeah sorry yeah it is it
is difficult to play this position black
it's not coordinated here and he's got
f4 and it just pushes forward not not
easy okay here Queen g2 is given is
winning by the computer yeah and quite
obviously actually yeah the point is i
calculated one roofer to mourn move less
than a must castles and bishop age five
and this is this is too much i'm winning
the data mahal look up that that's not
enough don't believe it still we have
white can try it blitz chess but ok this
I must have done but the whole thing is
really unclear quite quite tricky to
play there are various sacrifices of
this of this type here there is the the
famous the famous deep blue kirkus power
off game by 96 wassa was allowed by
Kasparov with a deadly attack until this
is this is comparable actually but check
I thought that with Bishop to e6 and so
on but but it's very tricky to play but
okay I shouldn't I shouldn't blunder
this 97 move this was terrible okay
thanks for watching